[Musica]
wow
ce la fa da dire wow insieme a me altre
mi aspettavo peggio
anche perché
[Musica]
wow e questa maschera e sono le uniche
due cose di cui vi parlerò quindi
facciamo così facciamo che siamo
bellissimi
siete un po bene
però siamo affetti da una specie di
miopia no e non riusciamo neanche a
vederci tra di noi delle volte neanche a
vedere dove siamo andati a finire
camminando girano in macchina
qui in sicilia peraltro io sono
siciliano quindi non mi potete insultare
e come se fossimo in immersione in una
specie di gel no
però qualcuno ci dice ci arriva da
lontano
ci arrivano delle voci che ci parlano
che noi siamo circondati da una bellezza
prepotente
e non riusciamo a capire
perché non lo vediamo bene
allora
ci siamo sforzati
e ci sforzeremo insieme di capire se
possiamo riuscire a vedere un po meglio
ed è quello che faremo stasera e
cominciamo proprio da wow
wow è una ricerca che stiamo conducendo
con io è un vostro cittadino d'elezione
poi vi dirò chi è magari avrà voglia di
dirvelo lui perché sono sicuro che in
mezzo a voi una ricerca che stiamo
conducendo e wow non è altro che
l'acronimo
di human ambien user che poi è
irreversibile no e quindi è proprio su
come poter mettere in visione nella
giusta visione perché di questo che
abbiamo bisogno in sicilia
tutta questa bellezza prepotenza che noi
abbiamo ovvero i beni comuni e beni
culturali
per fare questo ci faremo aiutare mi
farò aiutare da una serie d
testimonial particolarmente famosi che
riconoscerete
questi testimonial sono innanzitutto
ecco quello che dobbiamo fare
dovremo innanzitutto provare ad avere
dei superpoteri
per poter riuscire in questa cosa di
vedere meglio no infatti ho messo questa
pupilla inquietante con questi due
questo con queste due pupille e oscar
pistorius che comunque le sue gambe
riesce a gareggiare alla pari con
tantissimi altri delle volte anche
esagera come ben sapete è stato
condannato e questo è un po il mondo che
ci circonda la pressione nelle
multinazionali
e la politica che fa fatica fa fatica
perché perché in qualche misura abdicato
a questa pressione costante delle
multinazionali no e quindi applicato ai
gruppi di interesse in qualche misura i
gruppi di interesse che ci inibiscono
l'utilizzo e la piena nostra espressione
libera nello spazio pubblico e la prima
e promuovendo una sorta di estetica
della sicurezza mai come in questo
momento in cui la pandemia ha devastato
il mondo ci siamo accorti di questa cosa
no di essere ipercontrollati verso
svegliati lo eravamo anche prima lady
gaga è la prima testimone che ci aiuterà
era giusto per dirvi che
le dica che è stata la prima artista a
farsi vedere
con tante miss sempre tutte diverse
tante facce farsi vedere persino nella
sua intimità con la bruttezza di chi si
sveglia al mattino e c'ha pure le
occhiaie perché qual è il messaggio
questo ha messo in crisi tutti critici
della comunicazione perché perché
cercavamo sempre di farci vedere nel
migliore dei modi se pensate ad alcuni
luoghi famosi ad esempio come la nike
cell hanno
bombardato questo logo continuamente
addosso è
diventata una cosa quasi inestirpabile
da noi no questo perché perché forse noi
vogliamo essere in quel modo non sempre
cangianti no quindi il messaggio è
quello che dobbiamo accogliere nella
nostra quotidianità altri nuovi
parametri che sono quello dell
impermanenza senza dubbio quello della
transitorietà è quella della
provvisorietà e questo perché lo dico
questo lo dico perché allora quale può
essere l'unico modo l'unico modo può
essere l'estetica della sicurezza poi ha
portato a quelle cose l'unico elemento
buono è stato il maggiolone
che è stata l'auto piu venduta del mondo
perché era l'auto del popolo ma poi
insomma non è un buon esempio no quindi
un pianeta estremamente controllato e
noi siamo un po come quel topolino sui
trampoli che cerca di muoversi in mezzo
alle trappole non ma dobbiamo
riconquistare il nostro spazio pubblico
il nostro spazio vitale che oggi sono
confinato qui è il format che lo
richiede e faccio estremamente fatica ma
la maschera mi servirà ci servirà a
tutti noi per poter avere questo slancio
no avere superpoteri e un po come the
truman show dunque la prima cosa
possiamo fare questa eliminare gli spazi
interdizione ora
puoi fare pressione quanto vuoi con le
tue economie promettendo i posti di
lavoro quello quell'altro ma la gente
non è stupida e quindi si organizza non
è un caso che negli ultimi 10 anni
la gente ha occupato la piazza i ragazzi
la rivoluzione degli ombrelli di hong
kong ragazzi di 17 anni hanno messo in
crisi un governo l'ha messo in crisi
semplicemente occupando lo spazio
pubblico
era questa la protesta occupare prendere
posizione nello spazio pubblico perché
non è previsto non dovremmo dovremmo
andare da casa nostra i luoghi di lavoro
quindi di produzione e la luoghi di
produzione dell'economia
quindi centri commerciali negozi e così
via
e questo è accaduto in tutto il mondo è
dilagato è una confessione
transgenerazionale avete visto quel
vecchio signore perché ha contagiato un
po tutti e come tutte le rivoluzioni poi
vengono fuori anche delle nuove
traiettorie creative e noi l'abbiamo
visto la grafica
installazioni tutte fatte nello spazio
pubblico allo scopo di comunicare
questa è la rivoluzione in egitto
ma poi da queste cose vengono fuori
anche delle cose bellissime come quel
crocifisso dove ci sono le tre religioni
monoteiste più importanti del mondo ad
esempio questo fatto con siciliano un
designer che si chiama gaetano di
gregorio e vi assicuro che questo
crocifisso in tutti i posti dove è stato
messo acquistato ad esempio negli
ospedali è stato rubato
questo per noi designer è un ottimo
indicatore del fatto che l'oggetto
funzioni e soprattutto che generi negli
altri nei fruitori una sorta di
prurigine quindi il volerlo possedere
che un buon segnale
chiaramente non è una buona azione ma è
un buon segnale
ma la stessa cosa ha fatto gaetano pesce
alla fine degli anni sessanta e la
migliore lezione quest'ano pesce dice
che quando è sceso in strada con i suoi
amici nel 68 della rivoluzione del
movimento studentesco dice proprio lì
quando mi trovavo in mezzo ai miei amici
capii che la cosa più importante è
benefica che potevo fare per dare un
contributo a questo movimento
studentesco che ha eroso tutta una serie
di rigidità ha reso il nostro modo più
il mondo più informale più friendly
diremmo oggi proprio lì ho capito che il
contributo più grande lo potevo dare
progettando un oggetto ed è lì che nasce
la poltrona up che non è un caso che le
prime i primi rivestimenti hanno proprio
queste righe non come i clown di strada
che indossano questo tipo di magliette
non se le vedete quindi c'è sempre un
legame poi c'era questa cosa dello
stupore perché prima la vendevano
sottovuoto quindi era una sorta di
delega creativa che il design trasferiva
al consumatore non quindi tula privi e
si materializzava eri un po mago c'era
una frazione sciamanica e occupa
chiaramente poi ha dilagato in tutto il
mondo e così via questo cosa ci vuole
dire le dica che cosa ci vuole dire che
noi per progettare il nostro scenario di
vita non dobbiamo dare fare altro che
disegnarlo e ridisegnarlo continuamente
ogni giorno non possiamo fare delle cose
ma per fare questo dobbiamo avere
superpoteri allora non ci conviene
essere hulk perché distruggeremo tutto
non avremmo la delicatezza quindi ho
pensato a superman ha ragione di questo
è nato questo libro che si chiama public
design game design terre della all'hip
hop community per la comunità delle
kaleka che quello cui vogliono farci
diventare
in cui questo libro utilizza delle
pratiche prese dal basso e adesso
vedremo degli esempi per riqualificare e
rigenerare
vivere dare una nuova definizione
fisionomica al nostro spazio pubblico
vi faccio soltanto un esempio ci sono
adesso tante iniziative una di quelle a
milano il design che non c'è
c'è una chat le persone comuni che fanno
delle foto e comunicano un brano di
città
che non funziona potrebbe essere
riqualificato e questo poi viene preso
in considerazione ma
c'è stato un esempio che cito spesso che
è quello della individuazione in una
contea degli stati uniti dieci anni fa
di tutti i punti dove esiste un
defibrillatore
ecco questa cosa è stata fatta con un
giochino a costo zero con una app come
whatsapp
e ognuno di noi poteva fare della foto
uscendo durante il fine settimana di un
posto dove
individuava un defibrillatore la inviava
alla chat è chiaramente con la tecnica
del videogame del videogioco c'era un
feedback e una classifica quindi io ero
dieci defibrillatori avanti rispetto al
mio amico quindi ero anche molto
motivato e la mia ambizione cresceva
bene in due mesi hanno completato la
mappatura di tutta la contea adesso
vanno a definire quasi tutti gli stati
federati degli stati uniti sempre a
costo zero con questa competizione e con
questo giochino quindi è così che noi
possiamo intervenire poi ci sono tante
varie iniziative riempì di like tuo
catino preferito change.org ve ne
arrivano anche a voi continuamente ad
esempio la cosa di cui voglio parlare
questa noi
siamo fin troppo sommersi da possibilità
consentite dall'era digitale è
l'ingaggio che la cosa di cui io vi
parlerò stasera e che voglio promuovere
e l'ingaggio analogico fisico perché
soltanto attraverso la nostra presenza
fisica possiamo veramente apprezzare le
preziosità che abbiamo la possibilità di
poter vedere attorno a noi e l'ingaggio
non può che avvenire in maniera
analogica al digitale semmai può
intervenire parallelamente è anche in un
secondo tempo come attività
complementare per poter
ancora di più approfondire determinati
argomenti su quel bene che noi stiamo
vedendo perché dico bene comune perché
anche il paesaggio è un bene comune no e
quindi e di quello che ci dobbiamo
occupare ma non riusciamo a capirlo a
vederlo questo ragazzo ha
progettato un sistema che attraverso
un'app nel telefono ti consente la
possibilità di poter è il luogo fisico
dove noi confiniamo releghiamo tutte le
nostre intimità ormai il nostro
telefonino e allora lui a seguendo
diciamo un po la logica della città già
progettato un sistema che ti permette in
qualsiasi città tu ti trovi d'italia di
poter cercare l'ashtag che l'ashtag non
è altro che una panchina con diversi
livelli che ti consente la possibilità
di potersi sedere riposare e guardare
monumenti o far giocare i tuoi figli e
quindi questo connubio questo matrimonio
tra l'analogico il digitale è una cosa
che mi piaceva tanto appunto per fare
questo ma di che cosa abbiamo abbiamo
bisogno noi abbiamo bisogno di tutti noi
non quindi fare un design con
laboratorio queste cosa significa
significa che in ognuno dei nostri
centri dovrebbe esserci un design lab
permanente
dove confluiscono tutte le associazioni
di categoria
del territorio le associazioni culturali
gli enti pubblici gli enti privati e
alcune aziende estremamente
rappresentative significative per
realizzare lo scenario della nostra vita
per fare questo visto che abbiamo a che
fare con delle condizioni estreme come
sapete il con il cambiamento climatico
siamo in una condizione di pericolo e
quindi per fare questo abbiamo capito
studiando la storia che il sapiens come
è sopravvissuto a queste sollecitazioni
che provenivano dalle condizioni avverse
del clima è sopravvissuto mettendo in
atto a condizioni estreme una creatività
estrema ed è quello che dobbiamo fare lo
possiamo fare ce l'abbiamo e abbiamo gli
strumenti quello che dobbiamo fare noi e
di realizzare un paesaggio risonante
cioè fatto di elementi come questa
maschera che ci possano in qualche
misura
disarmare e produrre noi un effetto
straniante tale che ci
costringa benevolmente a riconsiderare
tutto il nostro scenario che ci circonda
ma anche questo ingaggio
l'avete visto non quest'estate e sapete
quello che ha prodotto
infatti qui è colei che schmidt che il
direttore degli uffizi tedesco
e tutto questo ha generato
una serie di benefici quindi utilizzare
un ingaggio che può essere un oggetto o
un sistema di comunicazione
quindi stiamo parlando parliamo di
design dei servizi
in questo caso per fare questo dobbiamo
costruire una rete e una rete o
utilizzato delle immagini che parlano
della rete guardate questo
elemento di confine e un recinto come
diventa delicato sembra fatto ad
uncinetto quindi anche un elemento che
storicamente universalmente riconosciuto
come una barriera può essere
interpretato e produrre delle reazioni
profondamente diversa e con cui guardate
un condominio che sembra tutto pieno di
ricami ecco di questi semplice ne sono
tantissimi e sono degli esempi quasi
fatti a costo zero persino il toro di
wall street è stato
contaminato avvolto tutta questa serie
di elementi oppure come fanno in india
adesso con le nuove tecnologie digitali
prima lo facevano con i ricamini disegni
fatti a mano libro un po come nei nostri
carretti siciliani adesso lo fanno con
la stampa è quello che ho chiamato color
design game cioè il gioco dei colori con
un gioco dei colori possiamo fare questo
e
questa è un opera di land art fatto ad
esempio nel paesaggio
abbiamo dei vari saggi vincolati che non
vengono utilizzate a proposito di quel
disco se vi dicevo dello straniamento
qua c'è un esempio questi due architetti
barber e o servi in un contesto storico
importante come il victoria and albert
museum decidono di piazzare questi
pannelli a specchio per produrre un
effetto straniante
nello spettatore nel fruitore quindi
rendendo meno rigida la fruizione
un luogo quale il victoria albert museum
che ha una sua rappresentatività una sua
rigidezza che gli viene proprio dalla
storia e da un sistema di fruizione
delle opere che certamente non è
contemporaneo ecco chi dovrebbe lavorare
anche tantissimo sul public
merchandising
ecco io mi sono chiesto tante volte un
turista che viene in sicilia cosa si
porta dietro il carrettino siciliano di
cartone o il buco siciliano finto
scarsissimo detto tra di noi che siamo
siciliani
o la scatola di paste di mandorla di
cartone che ha una grafica veramente
orrenda ecco bisognerebbe lavorare
tantissimo con un merchandising dedicato
perché ognuno dei nostri musei dovrebbe
avere un merchandising dedicato
lavorando con la ceramica lavorando con
tutta la scorta della costellazione di
materiali eccellenti che noi possediamo
ecco questa è una borraccia
semplicissima che è stata fatta per
alcune città in questo caso io ho messo
la città di milano dove c'è un po
rappresentata anche la storia ma pensate
poco fa vi faccio vedere il cagnolino e
jeff koons al guggenheim guardate quanti
oggetti del merchandising riescono a
produrre economie no portachiavi e così
via chiudo con questa immagine
intanto mi piaceva mettere questa fase è
che il sacro ha sempre a che fare con il
sesso di stesso inteso come sistema
sensuale chiaramente non come l'atto
sessuale come qualcosa perché se noi
attribuiamo una dimensione sacrale a un
oggetto a un luogo avremo rispetto
immenso per quel luogo e lo terremo in
grande considerazione
ed è quello che dobbiamo fare
mi piace finire con questa immagine che
anche augurale vista la dimensione tedio
e di oppressione che abbiamo vissuto
negli ultimi anni questo è un opera di
olafur eliasson che è un artista è
quello che ha regalato il sole al
tramonto alla città di londra dove il
tramonto non si vede mai le condizioni
ambientali caratteristiche della città e
ha regalato a stoccolma e sulla terrazza
di un albergo ha regalato a tutti noi la
possibilità di poter passeggiare dentro
l'arcobaleno che anche li un sogno una
dimensione onirica favolistiche che
tutti magari
desideriamo in qualche misura
realizzando questo anello che vi
consente di poterlo percorrere guardare
la città dall'alto quindi avere una
visione
stupenda da quel luogo fisico in un
posto semplicissimo di grandissima
qualità dal punto di vista realizzativo
è che cambia tonalità man mano che voi
percorrete questo anello
ecco io ho finito e vi ho dato
l'imbeccata su alcune traiettorie che
noi possiamo utilizzare per poter
apprezzare riqualificare e vedere e
godere di questa bellezza prepotente di
cui disponiamo eni disponiamo tantissimo
vi ringrazio per la vostra attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]